amazing ain't it just look at this gay
it's like nature men for us to build a
stair right here so there's a pretty
good chance if you're watching this
video that you're a lot like me and
mobster hunter world is your first
monster hunter and that can be
intimidating because monster hunter has
a reputation for being complex and
requiring dozens of hours to fully
understand a lot of that may be over
exaggerating at least for this game
which i think does a pretty good job
introducing you to the game in an easy
way and then ramping up the challenge
but it's still a game that feels
daunting at times and there's lots of
little tricks and tips the game doesn't
really tell you or tells you poorly
so to help out you fellow Monster Hunter
newbies here's some advice I would have
found helpful when I first started
monster hunter world the first thing the
game asks of you is to pick out a weapon
and you start with a selection of all
major weapon types in the game the game
works less like a typical grinding game
like destiny where there are hundreds of
weapons each with different stats but
otherwise I'll feel kind of the same to
use and it's more like blood-borne where
there's only a handful of weapons all
with their own unique feel the big
difference with monster hunter though is
that you don't put points into leveling
up your character and their stats you
just have to worry about leveling up
your gear this means that every weapon
is viable from the start and the one you
use will be dependent on your personal
preference and skill with it so make
sure to visit the training room
something that the game doesn't really
do a great job telling you about you can
access it by talking to the palico in
your room it's a stress free way to
practice moves and even gives you some
basic combos now if you're looking for a
recommendation stick with the beginner
weapons the great sword longsword sword
and shield dual blades and hammer the
combos and mechanics are meant to be
simple for beginners compared to the far
more complex weapons like the charged
blade or gun lands which require hours
to get the hang of along with trips to
outside resources like video tutorials
and the wiki seriously you'll probably
actually want to spend a lot of time on
that wiki but the great thing about
weapons not being tied to characters
stat
is there's no reason you can't just
switch to a completely different weapon
30 hours in if you're looking to try
something a little more complex Monster
Hunter really tries to capture the feel
of being a hunter which means there's a
lot of preparatory rituals you'll want
to do before every hunt you want to buy
and craft basic resources like potions
make sure your armor and weapons are up
to snuff and visit the canteen for a
nice meal bonus the early stages of the
game aren't too demanding that you won't
need to think too hard and specific as
long as you have a decent supply of
basic items you'll be fine
you don't need to get too picky with
armor as long as the defense rating is
high and you'll always be fine picking
the chef's choice option at the canteen
which tailors the meal to the quest the
wait game is rigged you're gonna want to
start thinking a little more
strategically with monsters that will
kick your ass if you're not prepared the
monster field guide gives you all sorts
of important information like what kinds
of attacks the monster does and what
elements and ailments it's weak to
bringing more specific items like
antidotes and null berries to counter
effects becomes necessary picking a
weapon with the right element and
picking armor with the right defense
towards elements is more crucial so
another great thing to do is make
loadouts it's easy to miss but you have
the ability to create specific loadouts
for equipment items and meals I find
creating and then naming a loadout after
a particular monster cuts out a lot of
that prep time when returning from a
hunt there's also numerous shops and
stations back at the hub world of astera
that you'll want to remember to check in
on always check in with the ecological
research field to add more data to your
moscar field guide you'll want to check
in with the resource center to turn in
any completed bounties and always make
sure you're registered bounties list is
full bounties after all are the main way
you obtain armors fears which you need
for upgrading don't forget to collect
your harvest from the botanical Research
Center before the harvest box gets full
by the way if you don't have anything
specific you want to cultivate you can't
go wrong with honey which lets you
easily stockpile mega potions there may
not be much reason to visit your room at
the beginning of the game which made me
kind of forget it was there but once you
unlock the tale riders Safari you can
access it from there so remember to
start visiting so you can always be
sending out pala codes and collecting
rewards okay now let's get to some more
specific tips the Mille boost is great
because it gives you a sizeable boost to
health and stamina but if you faint
during a hunt you lose that boost which
makes the rest of the fight a lot
tougher and can kind of be demoralizing
you can regain back your health boost
though through nutrients so it always
helps to have some on hand for getting
back stamina you can use rations or cook
some meat with this cute little minigame
just don't mess up the timing or you'll
burn your food and the boost won't be as
strong here's a hot tip if you have
items you always want to craft like
nutrients toggle Auto crafting and the
game will make it for you whenever you
have the materials of course when you're
out hunting your prey you'll want to
improvise and use your surroundings
creatures like para toads shoot a mist
of paralysis when hit and flash bugs can
blind nearby enemies just be careful
because you can be hit as well there's
also the environment itself leaping off
a Ledge gives you an opportunity to
mount a monster for high damage certain
walls like ones with giant mushrooms can
act as free boards for cool attacks
there are tons of ways to use the
environment to your advantage and make
your hunts easier
hunting down monsters so you can make
some sweet pants is a lot of the drive
in Monster Hunter so make sure to take
advantage of the wish list and put any
gear you want on it the wish list will
break down exactly what materials you
need and will even hint where to find
them you'll get handy notifications when
you found a material for a piece of gear
and when it's ready to build saving you
a lot of trouble of checking in at the
Smith every time with each area of the
game you'll start with one campsite and
throughout the story you'll get access
to a second one however there are a
total of four in each area and it's up
to you to find the rest you can search
for yourself or you can cheese it and
join a quest with another player who has
already found one and then you in turn
will find it after that you'll get a
special bounty you need to complete and
then the camp is yours throughout the
story you'll be given a handful of
optional quest and while you'll
undoubtedly do some of them I want to
stress that it's within your benefit to
do most if not all of them a lot of
these quests get you fantastic rewards
like new items to cultivate at the
botanical Research Center or new
equipment like Mantle's even the
terrible terrible egg quests are worth
doing for the new canteen ingredients
not all of these quests instantly appear
at the quest board some of them you'll
have to find NPCs with an exclamation
point so keep an eye out for these when
walking around hope you find some of
these tips and tricks helpful for you
Monster Hunter newbies if you're a
monster hunter expert watching this
video you undoubtedly have dozens of
tricks and advice of your own so why not
leave some of them in the comments and
help out your fellow Monster Hunters
happy hunting everyone
you